all right we're gonna move on here to
our series issues that matter we're
taking a closer look this morning at the
challenges posed by China considered by
many to be our top national security
threat China's expanding global
influence directly competes with
America's military economic and
technological might the country was
repeatedly cited in last week's
Democratic presidential debate some
candidates took aim at president Trump's
approach to China the greatest
geopolitical threat to the United States
right now congressman Delaney
well the biggest geopolitical challenge
is China economic threat China China and
climate change China without a question
they're wiping us around the world
economically I think the president's
been right to push back on China but has
done it in completely the wrong way and
if you look at what China is doing
they're using technology for the
perfection of dictatorship CBS News
senior national security contributor
Michael Morell was deputy director and
acting director of the CIA and he joins
us now good morning good morning Tony do
you agree with that stage full of
candidates is China our biggest national
security threat I sure do
if you're gonna make a list of the
national security threats and challenges
facing the United States it's long
there's only one at the top and there's
a big gap between that one and
everything else and that's China what's
that what's the gist of the threat so
they pose an economic challenge to us we
used to be economic complements they
were labor rich we were capital rich
those two things fit together
now we're competitors and we're
projecting we are particularly
competitors in the high-tech industries
that will dominate the economic future
and that will also dominate the military
and intelligence future we're also we're
also military competitors they've gained
on us more rapidly than any other
country has in history militarily if we
had to fight a war against them today in
East Asia we would struggle to win and
could possibly even lose that war and
then third and third there's a political
challenge right so there's a there's a
competition for political influence
around the world between the United
States and China and we are now losing
that challenge very aggressive and sort
of like in Africa for
sample they've been very aggressive in
Africa in Latin America particularly in
East Asia which they see as the place
that they should dominate they dominated
it at once historically they lost it
they think it's their right they want
that back what are the implications you
think of China's theft of our
intellectual property so I think it's
huge billions and billions of dollars a
year of stolen intellectual property
that they share with their firms that
make their firms more competitive
against our companies so it's
significant and they're one of the few
countries in the world that do this the
United States of America has never used
its intelligence capabilities to steal
intellectual property for competitive
advantage you're not gonna hear many of
the 20/20 candidates say anything nice
about President Trump but do you think
he deserves some credit for standing up
and calling China a problem yes so he is
probably the first president who has
stood up and said here's all the things
that China does that we don't like
particularly focused on the economic
side so stealing intellectual property
unfair trade practices demanding things
of us companies in China that we would
never demand of Chinese companies here
so he gets credit for that right but he
hasn't been effective yet in changing
any of those and he is not looking at
the bigger strategic picture that we
just talked about he's focused on only a
narrow slice of it well Mike how do you
deal with China's growing influence then
how do you fight this so this is the
tough question and there's nobody in the
national security realm who's figured
this out yet a lot of people are working
on it but nobody said here's the
solution but I'll tell you this there
are two must-haves one must have is that
the US needs to lead in the world and
particularly lead in the challenge
against China and then we need to put
together a coalition of nations who's
going to work with us I think the
biggest strategic mistake of this
administration has made has been pulling
out of the trans-pacific partnership
because that's exactly what the
trans-pacific partnership was a group of
nations saying to China if you want to
play in the world in a big way you need
to play by the rules not by your own
rules let's talk about the trade talk
say they're on they're off now they've
resumed again what do you think of the
president's approach to that so I would
rather fight these economic issues in
the world
trade organization rather than through
tariffs because tariffs at the end of
the day undermine American consumers and
I don't think that's a good thing so I'd
rather fight it out in the structures
we've already built rather than in a
very nasty public way what do you make
of what's going on in Hong Kong all the
protests and the challenge effective to
lead to Chinese Authority so this is
this is an example I think of what we
were talking about earlier in terms of
China wanting to dominate East Asia yeah
the Chinese told Hong Kong in 1997 that
were one nation but two different
systems you can keep your political
system and since 1997 those political
freedoms have eroded year by year by
year but you knew that couldn't didn't
keep its promise yeah and it's driving
them towards driving Hong Kong towards
the authoritarianism we have in Beijing
yeah and you do you think that's
inevitable it's inevitable thanks for
all the chills good to see my way to see
you